それから仏教のセクション
ちょこちょこっと この思考についてお釈迦様がどう考えているのかということ
俗世間的事実と普遍的真理
で コモンセンスということとトゥルースということ
次に あの俗世間の事実
単語を変えても事実と真理にしています
科学 医学 数学 経済学 政治論などは正しいと世間が認める
人間の役に立つ文化的な思考もありますね
ある立場から ある角度から観察すると
それらの意見は合っているんです
全く科学者がちんぷんかんぷんなことを言っているわけじゃないんです
お医者さんがちんぷんかんぷんなことを言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
その研究角度から見ると
ちゃんとした答えなんです
政治論を語る人はいい加減なことを言ってるわけじゃないんです
それなりの その尺度から見ると
そういう結論に達するんですよ
だからそれは仏教は間違っているとかなんとかとあんまり言えない
それはもうコモンセンスということで
世間常識ということで
これは仏教ですが  partial 英語で言えばね
partial トゥースですね
で パッチエカサッチャと言うんですね
いわゆるある角度が必要なんですよ
道徳を無視する生き方を生き方を
あ 道徳を無視する生き方ということ How
to live ということ
どのように生きるべきかということを教えてくれない
無知 迷信を支える哲学
宗教 祈祷 呪文などはもう拒否
仏教は哲学には悪口言いませんだけど
哲学で道徳を否定するならば
もう明らかにあんた邪見だと
哲学者もくだらんことをペラペラ言いながら
やっぱり道徳は守るべきだというならば
まあそれはそれなりに
あなたの見方から見ればそうでしょうということにするんです
だから絶対的な神の信仰を
迷信をお釈迦様は道徳基準で無きにさっぱり邪見だと否定するんですね
相手の論理で 神は全知全能
万能であるならば 過去現在未来
すべて知っているならば
神に知らせて何一つも怒らないであるならば
この世の中で何もする必要ないんだよ
人が人殺ししても それは神は前もって知っていたんだと
罪にならんでしょうと
それ考えて世の中成り立たないでしょうと
だから邪見である だって事実に反対だから
人殺したり強盗したりでは
この社会は成り立ちません
この世の中で正しく頑張って
真面目に仕事をして 人に迷惑をかけない人々は生き続ける
まだそういう人々たくさん欲しい
それが事実でしょうに
その事実に向かっても逆らいますからね
神の思考は 科学者には悪口言いませんし
地理学者にも悪口言いませんし
お医者さんにも何も言いませんしね
小説家にも何も言いませんし
芸術家にも何も言いません
ただ 時々お前はくだらんことばっかりやらないで真面目にしなさいとは言いますけどね
でもそれはそういう人々はにこっとそういう教えは受けるし
疲れて壁にぶつかったところでお釈迦様に会うでしょうに
お釈迦様はその時はちゃんと道を教えてあげるあげるし
しかし 邪見だけは だから芸術にはお釈迦様は全然一言も言ってないし
まあいろいろ能力も褒めたりもするし
しかし ある芸術家に あのもう笑いタレントなんですね
伝統的に それでも伝統的な笑い芸人だから
まあものすごい宗教みたいな感じで学ぶ
それで自分の父親 師匠ですね
それから師匠の師匠代々通して
この人を笑わせることはとても良いことであると
とても良いことをしているんだから
正喜天という天国に我々芸術家はみんな生まれ変われますよ
だから頑張ってくださいと
仕事はと自分の師匠に言われましたよ
いて これがこの人はすごく信仰して
お釈迦様は笑い芸人には反対じゃないんです
人を笑わせてお金をいくらかもらって
それでいいでしょうね
これはちょっとおかしいんですね
お釈迦様 これを言うんで
私は笑い芸人であると
しかし 私たちの師匠はね
師匠の師匠 あなたにまででもこういう風に宗教的に我々やってますよ
これは芸能じゃなくて
芸術じゃなくて宗教なんですね
それでまあ笑輝天 笑輝天って名前は日本語に訳すると
え？笑う 笑う うん 笑輝天に生まれますよと
そしたらお釈迦様があのね
これからまあ 10億  10光年ぐらいね
20 光年過去を遡ってみてもね
人を笑わせて天国に行ったという人はいませんよ
人を笑わせること しかし
そういう考え方を持っている人々はね
あの笑輝という地獄があるんだと
人を笑わせて罪を犯したっていうね
あの地獄には結構落ちてますよと
言うと この人すごくショックを受けちゃったんです
だって お釈迦様にはすごい能力があるっていうことも明らかですからね
また 嘘を言わないでしょうに
ちょっと脅すためにでも嘘は言わない
でもう泣き崩れて まあだからあんたに私のこと聞かないで言ったでしょ
最初から言ったら いいえ
私はそうじゃなくて 我々はいかに代々通して騙されていたのかということに悩んでますよ
それは悔しいんだよということで
人はもうそれで仏教を実践することになりましたし
別に笑い芸人辞めたわけじゃないんです
これは訓練を受けてもう腕が上がる
プロだからね 仕事として人を笑わせる
あんた方は笑って悲しみもなくて
家に帰ってください それから真面目に頑張ってください
それで終わっちゃいます
自分も人を笑わせて金儲けたんですけど
自分も心清らかにしなくちゃいけないんだということでちゃんとなっただけなんです
ですから 仏教は別に芸術やらあれこれ学問には何一つも言いませんし
昨日もどんな本読めばいいかという質問がありましたけどね
こんなことは仏教徒に聞くんじゃないんですよ
あの本を読むなよと言えませんよ
仏教の立場からは それはキリスト教の人から
イスラム教の人から 法華経を信仰する人から聞けばいいですよ
般若心経を信じる人とかね
そういう人はこれが読んで
これは絶対読むなよとはもうしますけどね
我々言えません 何読んだっていいんじゃないですか
何を学んだって  そういうことで
この俗世間の事実 真理ではないんです
まああまり差がないんですけどね
事実 真理の場合は まあ英訳すれば事実は facts ですね
真理は Truth ですね
次に この 知識は常に未完成ですということ
たとえ科学的数学的事実であっても
それらは人間の見方であって
普遍的な真理にはなりません
数学でもある角度から見たらの見方なんです
人間以外の生命は自分なりの世界観を持っています
人間は人間の世界観を持っている
そちらには科学もあるし
宇宙工学もあるしね もう微生物
何といいますか マイクロバイオロジー
そういうものもあるし
いろいろそれは人間の世界
人間の世間世界観です
しかし カラスのはカラスなりの世界観がありますよ
犬には犬なりの世界観がありますよね
他の生命体にはそれぞれ自分なりの世界観があります
生命に自分の命を支えるための知識以外
知ることはほとんど無理です
知っても役に立たないんです
だから人間が科学を開発して宇宙の秘密をばらしたそうと言ったっても
大したことないんですよ
あれは人間の命を支えるために必要なデータ以外はなんでもないんです
宇宙のことももういじっていじってないんですよ
ただ妄想思索ばっかりなんですけど
あれはちょこっと金儲かってるだけなのに
仕事はあるんだっていうこと
それで聞く人々も喜んだりして
何か新しい星を発見します
すごいでしょうとかね
我々馬鹿どもたちが喜んだりするし
それでその人々は生きてはいるし
そんなもんで だから大したことはない
それでもうもう 宇宙でギャラクシー何個あるのかって
カラスにも教えてあげてください
カラスにとって宇宙が丸かろう平らかろう関係ないでしょうね
なぜならば なんでカラスそれわからないんですかね
カラスにはそれでは命を支えることはないんですからなんですよ
もしカラスは三角形のあれの面積を計算するあれ数式知らなかったら大変なことになるのはみっくびに知っていると思いますよ
それだったらカラスが学校を作って教えてあげたりします
これこれわからなかったら
もう食ってはいられませんよと
ですから この たとえ科学であろうか
それは人間世界のだけのことで
人間の世界観ですよ だから各生命は自分なりの世界観を持って
それで無事に生きています
というわけで 真理とは言えません
2 たす 2 は真理ではありません
それは人間だけに 2 たす 2 は 4 であるというね
真理がありまして 他の関係ないんですね
他の生命には  2 たす 2 は 4 であろうとも 8
であろうとも もうカラスは生きていられます
猫も生きていられます
しかし  2 たす 2 は 4 6 やと思っている人間は生きていられませんね
大変なことになります
それだけの話 実際の世界では
2 たす 2 は 4 になりません
実際の世界では 例えば石 2個持ってきて
そちらにもう石 2個入れたら 4 になりますかね
それでも 1個1個の石なんですけど
一緒になってないんです
では一緒に溶けておく
それ 1個なんですよ そうすると 4 になってないんですね
で 重さがあって 重さはまた数字で計算するんだから
成り立たないんですよ
理屈上は しかし 石を 4個溶けて 1個にしたっても
人間はいえ  1個は 1g でしたからね
それで 4個だから今測ってみろ
4g だよと だから 2 たす 2 は 4 であると決めちゃうんです
それは人間には必要ですよ
その知識は生きるために
ビニール袋はまあ 5 キロぐらいは大丈夫やと思ったら
これには 10 キロぐらいの重いものは人間なら入れません
破れますからね だからビニール袋はこの重さに耐えれるか耐えれないか
ちょっと手で確かめてみるんです
あ ちょっと危ないけど
もう 1枚を入れておくんです
それは人間の世界の事実ですよ
しかし 真理にはなりません
そのすいません はい 生命に自分の命を支えるための知識以外
知ることはほとんど無理ですじゃなくて
無意味の方がああああ
知ることはできますよね
え？人間にはちょこちょこと頑張ればできますけど
それでも無理って？ほとんど無理っていう単語を私はもうわざと言いました
入れたんですよ 無意味と言っちゃうと
例えばカラスには  どうやってあの 2の3乗を教えますかね
じゃあ我々で計算考えましょう
あの 私はいつでも言う例えなんですよ
草ありますね 草はヤギさんにとってはごちそうでしょ
草とか葉っぱとかね これ見るとヤギさんがよだれも出ますよ
それでヤギさんにとっては草はごちそうであって
美味しい餌でよだれまで垂らす
では 我々にその同じ経験を感じられることはできますかね
全く無理ですよ 我々にとっては
うなぎの壁を見るとよだれが出るかもしれませんだけど
草を見ると全然食べ物という感じがしません
例えば人間は肉を食べる
しかし草って もうウジ虫がまでうようよしている
もう死体がもう動物の死骸
死骸があるとしますね
それを見ると あれ ハイエナがすごく喜ぶんですね
パクパクと食べる それでハイエナが腐った死骸を見て感じるあの喜び
人間には無理ですよ じゃあ 1億円あげますからね
そう感じてください  1億円じゃなくて 10兆円あげたって無理です
例えば視覚にしたっても
で カラスとか飛ぶ鳥たちでしょ
だからカラスは世の中をどのように見ているか
すごい広大範囲で見ているんですよ
5メートル 10メートルぐらいのところでぶつかりそうと思わないとね
だから上から見ているんですね
だからカラスに見える木と我々に見える木はね
違いますでしょうしね
まあたまたまあれ ケーブルカーとかなんとか乗って下を見るとね
それを見ながら 私はあの筑波でしたっけ
筑波じゃなくて 名古屋のね
なんとかどこかであったんですね
万博が そこでケーブルカーに乗って下を見ながら
なるほど カラスならこういう風に見ているでしょとかね
そこら辺 カラスが飛んで行ったんだからね
でもそれでもカラスの経験じゃないんだから
こっちは座ってるんだからね
あれはずーっと空気の上で動いてますからね
まあそういうことで ちょっとほとんど無理っていう方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
知っても役には立ちません
真理に達する 英語でキリスト教の単語を使ったんです
ブッダが一切生命に普遍的な真理を発見したんです
だから カラスの世界観でも
犬の世界観でも 人間の世界観でもなく
生命たるものは何なのかと
真理  第1 生きることは苦である
カラスにも同じでしょう
石原さんに随分邪魔されちゃって
で 真理には生に執着 それかつ愛ですね
するから苦が続くんです
真理第三 渇愛を根絶すると苦が消える
渇愛が混在すると苦が消える
これは弱情状態ですね
真理 理性に基づいた生き方と客観的な観察で真理の発見とともに渇愛が消えるという真理はそれだけです
それがすべての生命に共通するのです
だから ややこしいループ作って知識作っても作ってもすべて未完成なんですよ
これでちょっと書いてないんですけど
ちょこっと説明します
例えば 我々人間同士でも
人が怒って気分がもう機嫌が斜めになって悪くいるんですよ
私にはどう頑張ってもその人の気持ちはわからないんです
逆に人がなんか美味しいものを食べている
どんな美味しさでしょうかと
私にはわからないんですよ
これ 私も同じものを食べてみたっても
それは私が感じる美味しさであって
その人が感じたものじゃないんですね
しかし お釈迦様がそうじゃなくて
入るデータを受け入れない
で 受け入れてますけどね
結局は しかし 受け入れたくないという拒絶感情を起こる
音が入るともう取ってますよ
でも聞きたくないと感情で終っちゃうんです
そうすると怒りが生まれるんです
そういう説明なんです
それでカラスにしたっても
音が入ると感情で聞きたい音もありますね
キャーとか鳴くことだったら
カラス同士では聞きたいでしょうに
で 他の音は聞きたくない音もあるかもしれませんよ
で 聞きたくない音が入ると
カラスにしたっても拒絶反応は起こる
例えば動物に怒鳴ったらと
動物怖くなるでしょうに
あれは聞きたくないんだからでしょうに
それでその入った情報を拒絶する感情が怒りである
だから感情です 理性じゃないんです
理性だったら 人はギャーギャーと私のことを怒鳴っている場合は
怒ったってもどうしようもないんですよ
音は聞いているんだからね
受け入れてますよ だから関係ないんで
怒るかもう楽しくなるかということは
口に何か入れた食べ物
すごくまずい なんだこれ
まずいと怒るでしょうね
あれ もったいないで あの怒りはもうとっくに味わってるんだからね
だから受け入れたくない情報を遮断することができればありがたいんですよ
その方が理性的なんですよ
あの人々と話で世間話になっちゃうと気持ち悪くなるんだよと
それで じゃあそのグループに行かないことにすると
それは情報を遮断することです
行ったならば もうしょうがないんです
その人々の世間話を聞かなくちゃいけないんです
聞きながら なんで嫌なやつらですね
なんでこんなくだらんことを言うのかというと
感情的になるともう大馬鹿者なんです
もうとっくに聞いてるんだからね
だからそういうふうに説明することが共通的な真理を語ることなの
怒りは何ぞやと だから仏教はすごい科学と同じく厳密に定義するんです
全部この原子単位で取るんです
怒りという この情情的に大ざっぱでは取りません
情報に逆らおうとする感情
情報はいらっしゃい 入ってほしいという感情が欲で
情報整理整頓しないで受け取ることが常項なんです
ただ ぼけーっとしていて
あっちから入る こっちから入るとかね
例えばこの興奮状態になるでしょうね
で 面白いんで 興奮状態だと頭が悪いんですよ
機能しないんで あれこれやとか
例えば神経質になる人に限って全部
例えば人の前にしゃべることになったらと
ちょこっと人が言っただけでも
それ聞いてるんです もしかすると
あの人嫌がってるかもしれませんとかね
誰か立って出て行ったら
あの人腹が立って出て
そういう気持ちになっても
もうとっくに神経質になってイライラしていますよ
それとしゃべれないんですね
無我状態に陥っているのに
情報を入れているんです
だから落ち着いていると
この情報は入れないんですよ
そういうふうにこの原子レベルで説明すると共通しています
だから 嫉妬ということを見れば
猫の嫉妬も私の嫉妬も同じなんです
結構嫉妬しますよ 猫も犬も
自分のお隣の猫を抱っこすると
犬がえらい気分が悪くて
あれこれやていろんなことをする
それでも気にしなかったら結構悪いことまでやったりする
だからそれも嫉妬なんですね
嫉妬っていうのは他人の幸福を嫌がる
だから怒りの仲間なんですね
だから猫を抱っこして可愛がってくれると
猫が気分がいいでしょうね
ワンちゃんがこれ嫌なんですね
可愛いの俺じゃないかという感じで
だから人間の嫉妬も 動物の嫉妬も
神様の嫉妬も同じことなんです
うん